this tiny paper boat is being pushed
along by an acoustic hologram the ripple
on the surface of the water is created
by ultrasonic waves emanating from a
speaker underneath but crucially the
waves coming from the speaker passed
through a hologram plate some parts of
this plate are thicker than others where
it's thicker the waves take longer to
pass through and this creates a
distortion pattern as the waves reach
the surface they form the shape of the
ripple tiny invisible movements a bit
like a Mexican wave going around the
circle push the boat along using this
technique researchers can create all
kinds of patterns like this dove first
the team plugs the Dove design into a
computer which works out the structure
of the hologram plate a standard 3d
printer can then turn this digital
structure into the physical plate
in this case when this is placed in
front of an ultrasonic speaker the
acoustic waves push small particles
floating in the water into place
revealing the Dove it works for 3d
patterns tuned here the team is
projecting an acoustic pattern in air
the plates at the top of course you
can't see their air vibrating but adding
two drops of water reveals their effect
the vibrating air molecules hold the
drops in place so they hover and
spraying with water reveals even more of
the hologram this type of effect has
been achieved before using an array of
speakers without the hologram plate by
tuning many speakers researchers can
change the pattern of vibrations in a
way that allows them to move small beads
around for example this array uses 64
speakers but to make more complex
patterns you need even more by
comparison combining one speaker with a
single 3d printed hologram plate is
equivalent turn array of about 20,000
speakers techniques like these could one
day have applications in medicine
doctors already use ultrasound to treat
problems like kidney stones this
technique could help them to focus the
ultrasound pattern right where's needed
but for now researchers are having fun
getting to grips with the 1 2 3 of
acoustic hologram design
you